there's a major development in the
Britney Spears crazy family dynamic
apparently her daddy has had enough yeah
this could be big keV remember her
father was just accused of physically
abusing her oldest son and now he wants
out of taking care of Britain
[Music]
actually Britt no you dumped her dad
Jamie does and his duties include
controlling who she's allowed to see he
hires 24/7 caretakers arranges security
and if Britney needs a doctor or a
mental evaluation he can make that
happen and he also has 100% control over
Britney's fifty nine million dollar bank
account those duties - the money cart or
what Dad Jamie wants to hand over to
this woman Jodie Montgomery who's been
Britney's quote care manager over the
past year Jody's bio says she's a
dedicated Guardian of clients with
diminished capacities and special needs
adults each he has obtained the petition
filed by Jamie this morning saying he's
stepping down for personal health
reasons the 67 year old has been
suffering from major health issues
including a hospitalization late last
year the timing of this is interesting
on Tuesday kevin federline got a
restraining order against Jamie after he
allegedly broke a door and shook
thirteen-year-old son Preston for a long
time
Britney's had a rough relationship with
her dad's her fans got hash tag free
Britney trending in May and in just 12
days a judge may decide if Britney is
fit to take care of herself without the
help of a conservator
I think it's been clear that Britney
does not want this conservatorship any
more attorney tomorrow Armen act
represents Amanda Bynes conservators she
says this would be an ideal time for
Britney's mom Lynn to step in but what
Jamie Spears has done with this filing
is effectively cut her off at the past
and suggested to the court that the
court find a professional fiduciary is
actually someone better than a parent
remember Lynn supported Britney when she
was hospitalized in 2007 that was the
most horrible time because I felt so
helpless
how's Britney handling all of this
judging by her Instagram
she's good let's keep in mind that
there's a lot of money at stake
according to Forbes Brittany earned 30
million dollars in 2018 34 million
dollars in 2017
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]